I'm a hacker and I love hackathons now
hacker doesn't mean about breaking into
something illegally what it really means
is how do you with a group of people
break through and find a creative
solution so hackathons are way in which
you can for instance in a corporation
ask for and get ten volunteers from
different roles who are committed to
spending an intense amount of time in
some companies it might be a weekend
with pizza and to try to in a real
experimental lap time come up with a
unique solution right now some of the
leading medical device companies like
Boston Scientific are using hackathons
as ways of saying what's an
out-of-the-box approach to solving a
problem that traditional research never
got us to we believe that hackathons are
part of tapping the wisdom of the crowd
and increasingly we're gonna see
hackathons that aren't about physically
getting into a room together but are in
fact diverse and distributed around the
world linked by technology